hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the depths now
I've calmed down a bit I've stepped back
from my bitch's nature and I have
reassumed my own bravery those were all
fancy words to mean absolutely dick
because I didn't do none of those things
I'm just saying that I feel a little
better than I have before and I'm going
to do the tutorial to show how to do it
do a shark and then I was trying to play
a shark and then I'm going to try to be
a shark and that's going to be the way
that they do this thing I hate this game
anyway so I'm gonna try to learn how to
play and then I'm gonna try to be a
shark in a multiplayer match which
hopefully will be a little less
terrifying for me
oh god is this captain douche your
nutter oh yes please tell me about all
my life is less valuable than your
treasure uh-huh yes go on
oh yeah oh [ __ ] you want to be a
treasure hunter not anymore I've got a
mission to do this is a perfect timing
okay alright before I send you down
there let's get you off it why don't you
have an arm oh I know how to do this I
don't have money pistol Russian hardware
very nice okay that's a pistol alright
alright thanks alright I'm ready ready
all set there's that treasure out there
let's get going there's a treasure of
all God what do you mean by let's get
going you mean I get going and you stay
on the boat with one arm why do you have
one arm why tell me why ain't nothin on
my leg stay close so you don't get lost
okay sure alright then oh my shark
attack I'm trusting you to keep him in
one piece
uh-huh what about me can I be in one
piece I like being in one piece
oh yes [ __ ] god
damnit you'll be stapled in children
damage can be remote work with that
worlder [ __ ] you [ __ ] this mission [ __ ]
everything about this [ __ ] why are the
Sharks
in Reverse so we are here now your Isle
is not the right word we're at versatile
is not either vicious that's the word
not your island versatile I don't know
they're probably reproducing a whole lot
that would happen do you do you follow
my instructions now hurry up and grab a
truth they were carrying okay Oh Golden
Gun is the golden eye with the golden
gun okay right hey just oh oh hey hey
hey golden gun okay all right I'll just
do it what there's more okay
it just keeps reappearing it Wow
I am loaded up a bit rate work will
speed the profit you can buy some better
gear for your next time why do we split
the profit when I'm grabbing it get your
knife out to move faster oh okay go back
Steve take this oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] that up
oh [ __ ] whoops alright hang on got our
kit nope that didn't work yeah I does
ski okay got it
go faster with you everyone knows you
move faster with a knife bro every
little [ __ ] I don't want to do this I
don't want to do this
I'd rather I'm a gun Apple when I get
attacked oh boy please don't kill me
a little ice not on the map don't flare
down there for me we might find four
more treasures okay alright I will do
that bus for you that did not help it
just look like blah get it
laughs poor boy I've you [ __ ] bag and
back nine holy [ __ ] ow
a shark was relentless well you show him
most of all
what about my legs I seem to be quite
dabbling oh my divers the same thing I
flesh the ocean is a dark place you
never know when you will need a bit of
light huh yeah yeah about that
yeah also [ __ ] you well so what is this
place
this is it I knew pirates how is this
area to store the treasure damn
then look Ross a cha it's going to take
Steve a bit to get this open
give em coverage okay yeah all right
okay I'm gonna die
I've got like two how like he took a
bite of you go patch yourself oh yeah
maybe a little bit maybe a little bit of
a bite yeah let's call the bite let's
call it not my whole leg being removed
Oh that'll fix it oh it's an injection a
little band-aid double work underwater
okay oh [ __ ] where where hey yeah hi oh
[ __ ] I'm dead I'm dead
[Music]
our Haven Oh God oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude oh
[ __ ] dude huh oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
they must leave inside my buttocks oh
okay I got rash I'm thrashing
I'm thrusting so hard holy [ __ ] how do
you know that hey you know okay I seem
to be almost devil if you're going first
come on during those work my best
hey I prop up see how long you can last
oh geez captain Stubbs can talk to fish
that's a new revelation I did not know
that okay alright then carry on and on
out of it I'll break the ceiling I
didn't didn't know I could do that then
didn't know that was possible
Ibuki I did it I'm shark [ __ ] mark the
shark come through oh I got a feed Hey
yeah good job
whoa oh this bad honest I mean I know
its nature and all that but oh my god I
guess it's also sad that he's eating
humans but poor field goal
oh well jeez okay that's a little a
little ominous don't you think alright
whatever you know what I'm gonna take
your word for it
swoosh caboose key can I do up sweet
alright yeah look at me so what am i
what am i catching a whiff of here where
are they oh [ __ ] oh oh oh god oh god
whoa oh I got dead oh holy [ __ ] okay use
adaptive hide to hide from
oh boy Oh
feigning our our words yeah you'll be
back with more gullible Maroons that
haha let's just allow you to throw their
lives away into the waters okay well did
the tutorial
it was scary as luck ah what happens if
you actually killed Tony the tiger shark
I don't know I don't know but I'm good
to try to play I want to be a jerk maybe
uh maybe beg laDawn hunt I'll try beg
Allah Don hunt alright okay well
couldn't find a Megalodon match so I'm
just gonna do quick play and get another
one out of the way and then maybe in the
next episode I can actually play with
friends that'll want to kill me in every
way possible I'm a diver again which
means I'm under lot oh boy okay so this
time I'm gonna go with semi-automatic
that sounds good I can do that alright
already up I'm good I did it
what see this terrifying thing Venus
this is the if five round barrel that
doesn't why is it gonna have five
barrels in it that doesn't make any
sense
who designed these guns this is Captain
Steve designed these guns and sent us
down with his homemade [ __ ] oh that
guy's got a crown his name is coconu
hood that's can die two three and you
agreed to write out oh boy we're gonna
die
and again come on you hate the game so
much oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy yay yay oh boy oh boy oh
well that's a that oh oh whoa oh [ __ ]
well didn't get that Wow
[ __ ] goddamn it whoa whoa that one is
told the blooded apparently oh I get it
I get it I have to collect treasures
throughout the game whoa whoa whoa whoa
aah [ __ ] god damn it
oh Jesus okay respawn holy [ __ ] but at
least I got my treasure and I think
that's good well well that's not good
oh boy oh boy oh boy Oh miss no I got it
okay I got it
so this is how you buy stuff oh I get it
okay I got it now yes
all right why are we so separated it
doesn't seem good it doesn't seem I
[ __ ] got you
gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha
kichaka ciao - ciao and gotcha oh boy I
think good [ __ ] Ducker oh boy
well these are some disdain Juris this
dangerous this dangerous all this
dangerous all that's so dangerous oh
that's dangerous okay I cashed in my
treasure though I got a lotta money wool
boy oh boy
where are you where are you a-holes
where are you dillweed okay got balls
yeah yeah yeah thank you I did that
whoa where whoa that's not good
come on a green giraffe
I've got your back I think not really
but okay I can save it I [ __ ] goddamn
it huh okay but at least I can I can buy
a right oh wait no no self self self buy
this okay yeah I'll do that oh this
seems much better seems much BP better
whoa
[ __ ]
goddammit I just lost it [ __ ] haha
gotcha okay okay all right so far so
good
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy who's there
whoa whoa hello who's there that you're
there hi okay
oh boy okay to keep my gun
Wow I thought you got the Emmett oh my
god Oh Stabilo okay I need to go get
some goddamn help while they're
responding out of them a mother
okay got it okay I'm doing okay seems
like we're down a man but I don't know
where the last guy is he's all over the
place
god I can't see this boy see you there
ha ha ha ha ha ha I need by Blair's
quneitra any players well that's
whoa okay
getting some kills here I'm doing a lot
better you're not so scary anymore
you're pretty still pretty damn scary
but oh boy that's not good [ __ ]
gotcha oh boy that was terrifying or got
an almost a - bailed it
oh boy
where's that where's that oh hey no oh
my god there you okay thank you give you
oh I'm only got one round left
oh boy oh boy
why [ __ ] oh boy okay I'm officially
out of all it that's not good that's not
good om over there is keys he's cool boy
okay my gun out reload ah oh boy oh boy
where why is that guy why is that guy
going so far seems like not a smart
maneuver
okay I'm unstoppable apparently I've
refused to be stopped even for a moment
who way okay got you holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] they got me they got me they got
me they got me hahaha oh man I've got so
much money uh flares and see mine see
mine see mines
sure every fun I'll put this in the last
five woah that was scary but that's
still scary Oh God oh my god I can't
believe I made it out of that
well [ __ ] [ __ ] thanks for the medkit
okay I'll put put I'll put see mines on
the woo clock me full [ __ ] me will [ __ ]
me laugh at me cut off and after me oh I
I don't look so good the FEMA the sea
mines are not a good look for me well
that's not good oh boy oh [ __ ] where is
he
I'm working again oh boy come on come on
come on we got to get back in there ah
[ __ ] it again hello hello somehow I made
it out of that alive we get this medkit
hub okay okay let me place a see mine
right there that's a good place for it I
think I don't know idea where this acyl
is going oh [ __ ] that guy got that guy's
got a scooty to whoo scooty doo doo dee
doo where where where where
holy [ __ ] dancing oh boy well sounds
panic shooting now spray and pray method
wish I had a flare okay hey oh boy hey
clucking ah whoa I'm alive how in do
[ __ ] oh that is holy [ __ ] happen [ __ ]
my alive
whoo well this is Brian out worth it cuz
I'm probably gonna get killed anyway
whoa
got ya oh-ho you thought you could hide
I can see you for some reason
whoa where'd he go where'd he go
ow okay all right divers Wang yeah oh I
had the most kills I didn't get the
highest score but I got the most killed
yeah
I'm conquered my fear yeah oh yeah
that's cool man coconut go get it didn't
save us be the last player standing
against two opponents and win the game
whoa that's cool oh that was close
okay but either way that's good so we
only had a certain number of tickets
uh-oh that's what it was oh there are
you can only respond so many times okay
I did not know that huh
okay so anyway that is all the time that
we have for this episode here thank you
so much for watching in the next episode
I'm gonna try to play with some friends
because I want to try megalodon mode and
I want to try to be a shark and I want
to try to not be terrified in the middle
of the ocean so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]